Freak bitches,
I'm,
I'm interested to talk to you about a bunch of things,
but one of the big ones is this idea of effective altruism and this is something
that you really promote to the point where,
I don't know if this is true,
but I read this about you,
that everything that you make over $36,000 a year,
you donate,
so wow.
Yeah.
So everything above.
Technically it's having above 20,000 pounds from 2009 Oxford.
So just with inflation,
cost of living changes and stuff,
but that's about $36,000.
So you've just sort of decided that which is by the way,
the one percent for the whole world.
Yeah.
Not quite two percent.
Yeah,
I'll be in the top.
Still be in the top two percent.
Even despite that it was 34,000.
I think 34,000 puts you in a top one percent.
I think it's $55,000.
That was a changed maybe since trump's been in office,
but it's a,
it's,
you know,
what you're doing is a,
if that's really a case,
that's a,
that's a very charitable thing.
Yeah,
and it's also,
I mean it's most of my income over the course of my life,
like especially as an academic,
you're not going to an tons though,
since the effective altruism blew up,
you end up getting things like speaking fees and give all that away as well.
It's going to end up probably being the large majority of income,
of course,
of my life.
Do you ever like want to buy something and be like,
shit,
if I wasn't so goddamn generous I'd be able to get this,
you know,
I never do.
I like basically never think that.
Yeah,
I think like this.
Like I think like in contemporary society we just get bombarded with marketing
stuff all the time saying like,
oh,
you really need this thing if you're going to have a good life.
And I think like an almost every case,
that's just not true.
I think the psychological evidence just shows that once you go above a certain
level of income,
um,
additional money just has a very small impact on your happiness.
And in my own case,
like the things that make me happy,
I like being surrounded by friends.
That's for the gym membership,
that's like $40 a month or something.
It's not very much.
I can afford that.
Um,
being able to work and you know,
why valium,
passionate about and I already have that.
So my life is just so good in so many ways and I feel like there's so much of a
focus on money and how money is the key to happiness and it's just,
I think it's just all bullshit basically.
I liked that one moment,
like,
yeah,
we all have these moments where we feel bad and that when that girl said that I
felt better about,
like,
I was glad that I didn't go occur.
Did you stay friends with her?
Oh yeah.
I'm not mad at her.
I'm not mad at her and she had told me some sexual shit to it.
I didn't know.
It was almost like the shit you told me that I didn't judge you on what kind of
Shit?
Um,
she had had a fantasy.
I can say this because he doesn't even live in state anymore.
I,
she,
I wouldn't say this,
but I still saw her.
I would feel bad.
But uh,
she had a,
let's just say had a,
an,
and she'd never done it,
but she had had an animal fantasy or she had watched a video of an animal
fucking a woman and admitted it to her.
Something about it that had turned her on.
What kind of animal?
Um,
it was a pony
and
toys
pause.
It was funny.
He told me that she wasn't being dirty.
She was literally just talking to me about it.
Well,
it's a big fat hog.
Yeah,
I think I blurted that out.
It was a dog and pony hog.
Well,
there's a famous,
that's a common fantasy.
Women in horses,
a horse.
His Dick is so big.
You can't think about the horse without thinking about it's Dick.
Absolutely.
When you think about a horse,
like you said,
oh,
she'll dig on my thing.
It's just like,
it's a giant Dick.
My horse dicks are fucking huge.
What a great reputation.
Horses are such dopes.
Didn't know what a great reputation.
What was it like having him having him on here?
By the way,
Alex Jones,
it was a dream come true.
Like sitting face to face and talk.
Well,
I've been friends with them for a long time on that guy since 1999.
I think it was fun.
It was fun for me,
but it was also something like for the longest time people thought I was
avoiding having him on for some reason and he kept saying,
well,
I tried to get ahold of Joe Rogan.
Nevermind Tom and Tom,
but he blows me off.
He was always texting the wrong number.
He's always like,
he didn't get worried.
Get Ahold of me that day.
And I'm like,
dude,
I already have a podcast scheduled.
I can't do it today.
Well,
I'll be back soon when I'm back.
We'll figure it out.
And then it would go on.
I showed Joe Rogan's been avoiding me.
I've been trying to get in there to give out this information is very important.
Maybe scared.
Maybe he's been threatened.
The government threatened him.
He won't open up about bigfoot.
I believe Joe Rogan did experience bigfoot.
He saw he was there in the woods.
Oh,
Alex doesn't really believe in big foot.
I guess.
Who knows what he's got on?
I know he believed.
He seems to believe in demons these days.
Oh yeah.
Well,
they are demons.
They're all.
They're all demons from hell.
All of them.
They're damned.
I'm sorry.
And I apologize.
The apology,
the apology compilation.
Excuse me.
It's amazing.
I will stop your head.
Excuse me.
I gotta go.
This was a Christian family show.
It's like what?
I'm a Christian and I apologize.
He's just such a fucking awesome guy to me.
He's awesome.
He's,
he's like a boundless source of entertainment and if you knew him,
man,
like if you.
Me and him went out.
We went to a bar,
we had a couple of drinks.
We didn't have a great fucking time.
I'm telling you.
He's a really nice guy.
He's a real nice guy.
And he would start telling you,
well,
the Barium,
they've been putting Barium in the water and you're like,
what do you want another beer?
Like?
It's,
it's,
I'm telling you he's a great guy,
but I understand that people are upset that he has the president's ear and maybe
the president's like me.
Maybe the president just thinks he's awesome to listen to.
Crazy story trumps just like barium underwater sounds,
great.
Interdimensional child molesters are coming in through the cigarette,
smoke cigarettes with the 599 chemicals are designed to let the gates
of hell come loose in the interdimensional child molesters come in and he just
will go on and on and on.
The interdimensional child molester thing because it's like they have
interdimensional travel capabilities and they're like immediate thing.
Like,
what do we use this for?
I know what the kids will rape kids and other dimensions,
you know,
like what will there always is that really the best application of that fucking
technology and that fight.
First thing she does right away was he against Yulia bears.
Covich first thing she does punch me in the nose,
just shatters my nose blood everywhere.
I was like,
great.
This is again.
And it was right after the Kurento fight.
So it was like I was used to losing which.
And you never want to get in that space of being used to losing.
But somehow I clicked and you know,
I,
I did pretty well in the fight and I ended up getting a mounted triangle on her
and finishing with strikes in between rounds.
Another corner,
man put cold water in the back of my neck and I thought that I just farted.
I thought it was a Fart,
but turns out,
and this poor girl mounted triangle,
no less,
I had no idea of this.
So they grab us,
put us on this bus,
I'm still in my fight,
it's a blood limit,
gloves on and they just put us on a bus separate me and Amanda Buckner from our
corner men and everything because we'd want our fights and they take us to this
palace and I cannot remember who's pals.
Alexander something that was in St Petersburg and it was beautiful gold damask
and silk and just I'm in my clothes and I'm like,
what is that smell?
And I was like,
I'd seen a guy puking backstage because cars have a headshot.
I must've like rolled in it or stepped into.
I smell so bad.
And John Claude van Damme randomly walks up to us.
I mean it was just like,
you know,
faders here,
John Claude van Damme,
this and that,
like just weird and surreal already head trauma going on with me,
like not really in my right mind and I just,
it was so weird to be like smelling myself and being like,
God,
I stepped in.
Puke.
I'm sorry Mr. Van dam like that.
I smelled so badly.
That's so crazy too because you got punched in the nose if you smelled it
through your nose fucked up.
I remember being on the bus and looking around going say Miami perfume or
anything.
And people were allowed to shower.
But I was always a swing bat.
Right.
So I was right after put you on a bus.
Didn't tell me where I was going.
And that's a good way to get staff.
No kidding.
It was really gross.
I've been lucky with staff,
but yes.
So we,
I,
I ended up going to the restroom.
I'm looking at this shit caked all over.
Oh did I shit myself.
But I was like,
it must've been in between rounds.
Like there's no trash can,
it's like silk and gold and this beautiful palace and stuff.
So I just like take my panties off and just like roll them up and show them
behind the toilet.
Black Lace Thong Vladimir Putin.
That was mine.
I want to,
I want it back.
No,
I don't want it back.
in 2000 it was 10 years ago and it's crap.
Yeah.
So then I just go back out there and it's like Berlusconi was hitting on me and,
and,
and like trying to pick up and he was like,
Hey,
can I be your boyfriend tonight?
And I'm just like,
what?
But he's seeing it through a translator.
So it was so and I'm like,
I smelled like shit.
Like you are a dirty motherfucker
comes,
you know,
puts his arm around me and I'm just like,
this is weird as hell.
That was it.
It was just like I shit myself in front of foreign dignitaries in another
country.
That's probably my favorite MMA store
right.